nella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti adesso
video sono fa vj e sono convinto che con
l'abbia dei capelli più ordinati dei
miei è una cosa tipo sceglie personaggio
posso sarà una donna che più figo io
voglio essere donna che è finita la
carta igienica il futuro dell'essere
umano è nelle mie mani solo nella mia
sto giocando non fps sto giocando a
barbie dream house party 3 che possiamo
cominciare agazzi conciati così ma va
bene lo stesso chi se ne frega e
raramente c'è cosa ma per un accordo ma
dogma ma cos'è 6 superman
cioè io non ho mai visto una donna e del
surge i ragazzi c'è amore nell'aria
viceversa
vuoi anche i fuochi dati poiché io non
ho capito perchè perchè su per me mi fa
una pippa l'abbiamo capita su cosa
comunque devo saltare se io posso io
posso saltare dai palazzi non mi faccio
un cast ben presto giocano seriamente
non so come ho fatto a non scoprirlo
prima che giorno salve sono una donna e
regis è anche chiesto indichi e
maleducazione il mikele barber titoli
che cosa tocchi cosa tocchi d'appello
questo è un push gesto ragazzi mi
stuprano di capire che non puoi toccare
le poppe di una donna così perché ti
picchio posso dargli dei baci da lontano
i miei passi stendono
oh cazzo non volevo infatti baciare quel
bel culetto è successo giuro che non
avevo idea che sarebbe successa questa
cosa viene premuto il tasto è per
liberarlo cosa libero amico mio sei
veramente un figo cosa fai
con quanta contentezza avrò cazzo stai
andando a oggi ho fatto sei veramente un
figlio con i ragazzi a parte sta roba
fantastica di sotto si apre trentini
premuto per interagire questa cosa io
già lo amo sappiate ragazzi secolo la
sicurezza tutto ho capito no ragazzi ho
capito il senso di questo ci ho messo un
po ma l'ho capito praticamente ragazzi
c'è odio nell'aria io porto amore
ovunque a parte a te che sei brutta
presente devo denudare la gente devo
trasformarla in gente nuda
devo liberarla in modo tale da dargli
l'amore ai ragazzi questo è il gioco del
gioco di san valentino proprio che cosa
cazzo
fatemi andare avanti che non sa se io
veramente non ha fatto quest'oggi questa
si è fumato prima vera mente giuro
stavolta voglio capirlo e vado sopra
sopra la scala vai così diamo amore a
queste case a queste scale ragazzi sono
veramente una gnocca cos'è sta roba
la madonna dami e mazzuca era che cazzo
ragazzi io grazie alla pro prendo io
cabello è una figata non può veramente
come faccia ma ci sono più armi ma che
cosa troppo figlio dove è l'amore è
nell'aria dove noi lo stronzo cosa
messaggi vai a incontrare la tua donna
maledetto l'ho preso e adesso il nudo
perfetto madonna un cecchino ragazzi
cupido mi fa una pippa
mi sparano da quando possono sparare si
stronze fa eco perfetto ma ma se si fa
mimì mi sporgo riesco a vedere che cosa
c'è sotto cosa guardi la perché hanno
messo le censure ma non che mi interessa
se le vuoi liberarti per darti dei
vestiti decenti ecco che fashion ma
neanche zara propri ragazzi mi stanno
uccidendo mosso come mama 3 68 fa ma non
l'ho mancato va beh a parte sta roba
eccoci qua ragazzi sono fatta che bel
culetto mostrami l'amore è nell'aria ma
lì
ce l'ho fatta ce lo fa dove siete
un'intera ragazzi ma d'ora quanti sono
ragazzi parlano ma mica ma [ __ ] ancora
in una tripla una tripla un quad arda
riguarda che basta i miei baci che fanno
svenire tutti e non ho mangiato alle
realtà tutti sei vestita benissimo cioè
io voglio capire cos'è stanno mai gomez
lopez fix sembrava una parola brutta ma
c'è perché sa perché in questo centro
commerciale dove che patto di saperlo
teddy bear green ei ragazzi fatevi
provare questo questo ben di dio che
voglio vedere come funziona è la madonna
ragazzi sono troppi sono troppi chiama
green the walking dead erano così tanti
bastardi crepate mica del disastro ma
niente non funzionano gli stordiscono e
basta si cose da domani ma doni centri
commerciali ha spiato da file fare la
gente amico mio lavati che puzzi ok
perfetto ragazzi perfetto disastro
assurdo ma ce l'ho fatta
hanno bloccato le entra ma cosa ma
veramente se la madonna che cazzola non
so neanche come sia possibile questa
cosa ma va bene ho fatto amiche ammesso
ci ho messo delle ore per fa starò via
via via via via via via nell'ascensore
mica mi sembra di giocare a matrix
chiama 60 secondi i seri ammesse ora
esisterà mai nella vita 60 secondi ma ci
fa sfancula
ma non sulla strage ragazza si chiama
una bomba nucleare d'amore c'è per caso
voglio capire se sono solo io a pensare
che è una roba da cannati monte
liberation che ci siamo ragazzi ci prova
entrare qua dentro poche fenomeno un
fenomeno che bella la musica
dell'ascensore trucco cazzo ama mi
piazzo sono tenero credo di aver finito
non lo so non ne sono sicuro è però
dovrei ecco perfetto ci siamo
libero al mondo e ce l'abbiamo fatta
sebaste ragazzi non ne posso più abbiamo
fatta
forse a cazzo sa cos'è e godzilla devo
fare innamorare di me anche godzilla e
la madonna è la supposta che ti devo
infilare nel delle tante è una navicella
piena donna non lo fare ti prego non lo
fai ti prego non lo fargli bere non lo
fa reti per il costante l'ha fatto
e vabbè ce la mettiamo anche qualche
musica etica magari grazie sesta
navicella che primi tempi all'origine
dell'odio sembra un dildo volante io gli
ho dato sono salito sopra non sopporta
ciò uno stile che spacca il bosco i
ragazzi doveva essere il boss finale
credo e non ne sono sicuro tanto gli ami
atteggio come può qualcuno dovrebbe
spiegarmi così
cosa cazzo è questo è vero dice ma sti
cazzi va bè ragazzi devo battere il boss
che sarebbe questo devo dare dell'amore
anche a luino va beh io non ho capito il
senso di questo gioco completamente si
si crepa crepa migliaccio messo mezz'ora
per farlo mai [ __ ]
ma perché c'è un orso ma spiega tema sta
cosa niente rimane l'ultima volta
piaciuta dovrei aver fatto ragazzi vai
vai vai crepano vuoi vedere che non
muore adesso sul compenso che sto
facendo un presentimento
vai mai l'ultima soca ho vinto ho vinto
tutto è cascato la l'orso dettato questa
pancia che tito come penso che per me
l'orso si è svegliato mangiano vivo ti
prego marcelo vivo cosa perché
seriamente di dimmi che che sta
scherzando ragazzi che cazzo ragazzi è
stato stuprato da un orso bene bello che
bello o persone e occhiali e quindi ho
perso i superpoteri
ok dunque con la panza che si ritrovava
la vedo difficile che che potesse avere
dell'amore quel tipo è da un orso si no
mi sono sacrificato io veramente e
dovrebbe essere una scena toccante ma mi
fa troppo ridere perché non ha senso
ovviamente adesso mi sono sacrificato
ieri esplode la razzano sapeva c'è
proprio spielberg che cazzo ci stai a
fare su affari fini
bravi bravissimi gli occhiali per chiari
i nostri prego no agli occhialini rosso
vivo se vivo beh c'è io ragazzi a che
cosa cazzo appena giocare
dovete spiegarmelo io non ho capito una
mazza di niente dall'inizio alla fine
però ok questo perso nove ragazzi gioco
pieno d'amore e tante belle cose
un gioco con una trama e un finale che
rimarranno nella storia altro che titani
quello che episodi ragazzi come sa se il
servizio è piaciuto questo momento mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook e come
nei video travers chiziane certi avresti
discrete ci vediamo al prossimo video
ricordatevi che l'amore sempre dietro la
vostra porta e sperate che sia io anzi
non sperateci troppo bello ragazzi